[Musique]
on a des sites font des tomates et
camomille en 2016 au début notre plan
d'affaires stipulé quelque chose comme
est dix paniers par année pendant 10 ans
le dit c'est vraiment comme un à côté
pour profiter de la terre puis à amortir
les coûts les rats disons partie
malheureusement
finalement il ya eu un engouement assez
grand ce qui fait que six ans plus tôt
on est rendu à 275 abonnés de panier et
on fournit aussi le marché public de
bonheur
[Musique]
sur leur terre située à une trentaine de
kilomètres de la ville camille béchard
blues et son conjoint dom poirier se
prépare pour aller vendre leur récolte
aux marchés de rouyn noranda
alors vu du sud lâcher notre montréal on
s'imagine la victime est passée de la
roche prix des billets via ea qui pousse
qu'est ce qui pousse dans la médecine
mais finalement est un peu tous et
stocker et on est quand même une bonne
contrainte par rapport à notre seul qui
est l'autre les politiques au maraîchage
mais on apprend de plus en plus sale
travail et puis ça ne dépend rendement
qu'on le travail d'une bonne façon puis
on se rend compte que l'argile le nôtre
type de seul super résilient enfants de
sécheresse donc je regarde l'eau on a
moins besoin d'arroser puis ça donne un
goût vraiment très bon ou légumes aussi
donc on s'est rendu compte que ce qui
était au début une contrainte devient
vraiment une force
face à une saison courte les producteurs
maraîchers abitibien développe la
culture en serre il offre ainsi une
belle variété de produits un réseau de
sept marchés locaux dispersés dans cette
région de près de cent cinquante mille
habitants classe l'abitibi témiscamingue
au troisième rang quant au nombre de
marchés par habitant au québec vous
étiez surpris qu'on ait cette marchés
publics en région mais je pense qu'on
pourrait même posé la question à des
abitibiens qui en a qui savent peut-être
même pas qu'on ait cette marche et en
régions donc le fait de petites se
regrouper ensemble d'augmenter notre
visibilité d'augmenter aussi le
peut-être des associations entre nous
les différents marchés sont répartis sur
plusieurs jours de la semaine ce qui
permet aux producteurs d'être présente
partout où il le souhaite et on essaie
de pas vraiment sans pietrus les judith
est ici mais de ville-marie aussi mehdi
on est quand même assez éloigné le comme
région on essaie de se respecter comme
ça je pense qu'avant tout les gens qui
consomment des marchés publics consomme
aussi le producteur qui est à l'arrière
c'est pas juste la tomate que tu viens
chercher mais c'est de savoir d'où elles
viennent à thomas qui le produit que tu
la connais la personne en plus qu'il le
produit cette tomate ne le fait-on quand
la bonne longueur plus gros un temps
illusion il sent pas très grand on sait
d'où ça vient on fait comment prendre
soin aussi de tous les aliments qui font
pousser la de fer régional ces vieilles
faut qu'il faut encore encouragé aussi
nos agriculteurs de la dass à chaque
semaine c'est un plaisir de venir
choisir nos lions pourraient avec mes
enfants ça fait découvrir de nouveaux
légumes différentes façons d après tri
les marchés publics sont si populaires
que certain manque de place
l'achalandage et l'homme et aussi les
producteurs sont de plus en plus
présents et les gens viennent quand
c'est ma période d'inscription le cette
année j'ai débordé j'ai même été obligés
d'en refuser puis je pense que c'est la
même chose pour quelques marchés en
régions journée le 1er mars on a
vraiment battu des records de visiteurs
l'ont eu au dessus de mes 500 personnes
le premier marché oui après c'est ça
continuer à peu près 800 personnes on a
monté la popularité des marchés
paniquent on a fait connaître le on est
rendu ou s'il ya extension ni tous ceux
pour faire de la place aux six nouveaux
joueurs puis aussi pour eux pour étendre
l'accessibilité aux clientes et lui le
marché public qui le 4 heures une
journée par semaine mais il faut aussi
développer des choses pour les autres
journées de la semaine pourrait
rejoindre le plus de gens possible pour
rendre les produits accessibles pour
rejoindre plus de consommateurs la
région s'est dotée d'un marché public
virtuel il s'appelle goûter à tecom d'un
goûter l'abitibi témiscamingue
c'est un site web en fait c'est une
plateforme que vu le jour il ya trois
ans qu'une mission double je vous dirais
la première mission c'est d'être une
vitrine pour les producteurs
agroalimentaires et les agro
transformateurs de l'abitibi
témiscamingue donc on essaie de les
mettre en valeur en racontant leur
histoire et ont une boutique
transactionnel donc qui permet aux gens
de faire leur marché public en ligne les
gens en fait ce qu'on leur dit c'est que
vous n'avez pas le temps de venir au
marché ou si vous voulez réserver
certains produits vous pouvez faire en
ligne et les gens viennent aux pièces de
boue tat simplement récupérer leur
commande qui a tout était préparé
on est une région où il ya beaucoup à
évidemment de producteurs maraîchers
agroalimentaire produits laitiers
fromages il s'est développé aussi
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de produits
agro transformer dans les dernières
années
de plus en plus de chaînes
d'alimentation et d'épiceries fines se
lance dans l'achat local elle propose de
nombreux produits comme ceux de boréal
est une ferme laitière familiale de
saint félix de dalquier au nord d'amos
celle là c'est un lait de vache 2 les
laitages usines les plus riches en gras
en fait comme un peu la crème du lit et
pour le transformer si l'idéal parce que
plus que toute matière dans un hall et
de matières solides bien plus que celle
des appelants transformation et que
c'est pour ça qu'on transforme mais
aussi nous on n'en doutait donc les gens
craquent âge est un litre de lait est
retombé de lait entier ici le togo est à
peu près 5 points 5 % de matière grasse
en fait c'est ce qui se rapproche le
plus de ce qu'on va voir à la fin parce
que le seul traitement qui eût c'est
qu'on le pasteuriser on le pommeau j'ai
misé donc la crème vraiment
naturellement la surface
evelyne produit aussi du fromage mais
elle est surtout fière de son logo
inspiré du savoir faire français
tamayo golliot du les pieds les ferments
puis c'est tout on rajoute un petit peu
de poudre de lait écrémé canadienne pour
y donner un petit peu de textures pour
chercher la fermeté mais j'ai envie de
goûter aux graves très bon moi je ne
mange comme ça en tout cas oui
[Musique]
comme la crème à l'érable exactement
c'est ça ouais c'est vraiment très bon
non jacques besse bon oeil de new york
où je suis vraiment un très
bel prépare un logo au sirop d'érable
locale un autre aux bleuets sauvages
et tout comme ses collègues maraîchers
evelyne fait le tour des marchés
plusieurs jours par semaine une belle
vitrine pour ses produits
[Musique]
prochain défi pour les marchés est tirée
la saison au maximum à val d'or ce sera
possible grâce à cette structure
permanente on a une belle salle à
l'intérieur cette année on veut faire
deux marchés pour la continuité après
les deux derniers dimanches d'octobre de
fer spécial marché parce que c'est là
que les marchés ont le plus de légumes a
à offrir et le tout les marchés se
termine donc on aime vraiment se donner
la possibilité aux maraîchers devoir
liquider leurs stocks et aux marchés les
marchés publics dans les dix dernières
années s'est développée une fierté à
gros gourmand par rapport à les victimes
jusqu'à mende c'est une fierté ce que
nos producteurs font quand on reçoit des
gens de mettre ces produits là aussi sur
nos tables car les marchés commencent
quand les paniers commencé l'euphorie
zale de vraiment de voler les gens sont
contents que c'est leur petit bonheur de
la semaine de venir chercher leurs
légumes ce c'est vraiment une grande
dose d'énergie pour moi
[Musique]